Janet thank you very much Colorado
Springs police chief Adrian Vasquez
joins us now good morning to you Chief
thank you for taking the time I know
it's very hectic for you
good morning Gail thank you for having
me yeah I'm so sorry this has happened
to your community or any Community for
that matter but what can you tell us
about the status of the Wounded victims
at this time
well uh when I left last night we still
had a lot of work being done at the
hospitals so far the wounded victims it
does not appear that any of them are
credible critical or life-threatening I
should say so that was good news and
I'll wait for further updates later
today
I know this investigation is very early
very new still in flux are you prepared
to call it a hate crime at this time
not at this time of course we're
absolutely looking into those facets of
the investigation our detectives will be
coming through as much information as
they can obtain and determine whether it
was indeed a hate crime or not
now you know we keep hearing now in
these these shooting these mass shooting
scenarios the rule is run hide fight it
does seem that some of the patrons in
this club did exactly that that they
fought back what can you tell us about
the circumstances of how the gunman was
brought down
yes so absolutely two uh two at least uh
people with inside uh Club Q did exactly
that and we really have to uh pay them
great tribute for that and and uh what
we see what we know is that the gunman
Nazi entered the club immediately opened
fire and started walking through the
club uh doing so at least two patrons uh
engaged with the suspect and were able
to actually take him to the ground uh
and and subdue him uh until officers got
there and were able to take him into
their custody
and what can you tell as Chief about the
suspect I saw a video this morning of
police encounter with the suspect at his
home we're hearing reports that he might
have threatened his mother at some point
what can you tell us about him
yes so we're looking into all of uh any
any history that the suspect may have uh
right now I haven't been briefed it'll
be uh probably later this morning that
I'll get any briefings on uh previous uh
cases but I have not uh been briefed on
those at this point
it's about you Chief this is your
community one day really only the people
in your community know your name now
this has become a national story and the
nation is really hanging on to your
every word to give us updates I'm
wondering how you're holding up and how
you're feeling about this personally
well thank you I I am holding up very
well and I've got a great support system
both uh both at home and on the
department and uh you know I'm just I'm
just really saddened by this this is
tragic and it just feels like an evil
person has come in and done something
horrific in this community and that's
not what we stand for this Police
Department is part of the community I've
been a Colorado Native in my entire life
and I have lived in Colorado Springs for
27 years and I just terribly saddened uh
and you know Club Q is a safe haven for
this particular population and I I feel
like I need to reach out and make sure
that they understand the police
department stands behind them through
this event
yeah I think you're raising a really
good point I've seen interviews with
some of the people that were inside the
club that night God knows how
traumatized they must be and they said
this was our Sanctuary this was our safe
place this is a known Club in the
community what is your message to them
today how can they feel safe
yeah absolutely uh you know I went to an
event last night at Temple bait Torah
and it was all about
One caring for the emotions and and for
these uh the individuals that were
either in the club or part of the lgbtq
community and my message to them is that
they are part of this community just
like I am our Police Department is here
for them we stand behind them we're here
to provide them the Safety and Security
of every single citizen in this city and
it's just a beautiful city to live in I
want them to enjoy it and to feel safe
in our community
and you use the word evil to describe
the actions in this particular suspect
who's in custody I think many people
would agree with you what happens to him
now I know he's in custody what happens
now
so as of uh last night he was still in
the hospital at some point he'll be
released from the hospital and taken to
the Criminal Justice Center I've been in
close contact with D.A Michael Allen and
his staff for charging as soon as soon
as possible the the individual will be
charged and uh then uh the the next
steps or phases will be the DA's office
for uh prosecution of course our
detectives are continuing the
investigation that'll take quite some
time to process the scene do all the
interviews and so forth so a lot of work
yet to be done
all right Chief Vasquez we thank you for
your time sending you all good thoughts
today thank you sir
thank you so much